[Musique]
bonjour monsieur vous désirez une
conversation je
les prie monsieur vous les avez sur l'
annonce vous les avez son annonce les
prix ces 250 points les 20 minutes
bonjour mais chaque jour plusieurs
milliers d'appels dont plus de la moitié
en provenance du lieu de travail le sexe
par téléphone est une industrie en
pleine expansion dans la région
parisienne une quinzaine de sociétés se
partagent chiffre d'affaires de 10
milliards de centimes une activité
légale qui se montre au grand jour des
pages entières de publicité dans les
plus grands hebdomadaires un syndicat
tout récent une clientèle de plus en
plus variés grâce à l'anonymat toutes
les folies sont permises une nouvelle
façon de faire l'amour
oui
prisca vous êtes à la tête d'une
entreprise un peu spéciale en quoi
consiste-t-elle
pas des frustrés des gens comment
justement les dimensions découvre au
niveau du sexe qui n'est pas les talons
d'achille mais plutôt et levier vers le
septième ciel comme vous déterminer
l'origine de cette clientèle oui
absolument déjà par rapport aux supports
publicitaires
que nous faisons donc ils sont le nouvel
observateur qui sont parés ce câble qui
sont des supports spécialisés par
conséquent je peux vous dire que 50 %
voire 60 de notre clientèle est une
clientèle de cadres supérieurs
est ce que cette entreprise rentable
rentable certes après un guet démarche
publicitaire la démarche
d'investissement très importante
notamment par rapport au système de
crédit etc
donc
sais
tu m'as compris
à l'eau claire
alors oui moi une présenter je m'appelle
valises à je fais un mets très content
j'ai fait des yeux verts et des cheveux
bruns et toi tu es comment l'as-tu
allongé qui fait comment
ouais tu peux pas les un peu plus fort
je t'entends pas tellement oui
mais voilà la
70 e
mails et dont tu m'as l'air bien
excitant
tu m'as l'air bien excitant alors tu
sais ce qu on a fait l'amour kristen en
consiste votre métier a incité les ions
de quelle façon mais par la parole et
c'est par la parole je veux dire en
parlant de téléphone non en décrivant
quoi vous vous décrivez toujours de la
même façon
bah oui puisque j'ai des clients qui
font un habitué qui me téléphonent
souvent donc je vais pas me décrire un
jour blond l'agent bruno
comment deviner vous ce qu'ils attendent
de vous
ben c'est comme ça c'est sa force de
parler on a l'habitude de voir qu'est-ce
qu'ils veulent quoi vous arrivez en
quelques minutes saisir la personnalité
du client
quelques minutes
ouais trois bonnes minutes quand même pu
gagner beaucoup d'argent dans ce métier
ouais touche plus je travaille plus je
gagne quoi je veux dire que j'ai ici
deux personnes plus plus qu'elle n'en a
pas se plaindre
nathalie vous vous occupez du standard
comment ça se passe bien alors je reçois
des appels différents messieurs qui sont
éventuellement intéressés par une
conversation pour une conversation
érotique et selon leur leurs fantasmes
ou ce qu'il désire je dirige vers une
hôtesse ou si ce sont des habitués mais
je fais appel à leurs hôtesses comment
ça fonctionne avec la carte bleue et
bien lorsqu une personne à une carte de
crédit une carte bleue une dinars soit
une rocade même puisqu'il n'y a pas que
des cartes bleues nous lui demandons les
numéros qui figure sur sa carte d'adex
pire à sion et bang bang qui est remise
donc cette carte ensuite je fais un
petit une cohérence sur un ordinateur
afin de voir si cette carte est valide
voilà
oh
trois ans
bonne nouvelle doit se faire dans la
société vous avez organisé des activités
oui bon y'a
y'a du stretching le
parisien il ya des comédies musicales
il ya
bon il ya plein de choses sévi jeudi
c'est une vie ici inter interstructures
et un bon c'est une vie complètement
complète c'est-à-dire qu'on mange con on
se détend quand énervé quand et
complaisante qu on a fait l'amour le
soir donc on arrive le matin enchanté et
ses règles ses terrains
c'est la vie est-ce qu entre vous vous
raconter les conversations les plus
amusantes et et croustillant coiffer
une femme quand même
toujours éric le corre qui surprend
beaucoup c'est que rien ne circule ni
l'argent tous les jours par le décor
tout les tout se passe par ordinateur et
sucrés ou par par voie de câbles
téléphoniques
c'est bien c'est génial
du moment que les véritables rapports
humains sont conservés oui c'est ça qui
est important cette indication
célibataire soul eater qui vous appelle
oui on non mais il ya beaucoup d'hommes
mariés aussi donc c'est un complément
aux fantasmes de
vous avez l'intention de faire ce métier
longtemps
plus longtemps possible quelle était
votre activité avant de faire ce métier
est tetris est actuellement là vous êtes
dans cette société donc responsable la
société
vous avez été hôtesse oui vous y preniez
plaisir
c'est un plaisir qui est physique aussi
pour moi non pour moi c'est à dire que
bon qu'il ya des hôtesses qui ont joué
effectivement avec grande surprise
prenons enfin bon si vous avez des
frissons vous avez des vibrations qui
passe vous sortez des composés après une
conversation parce que vous êtes
amoureuse parce que enfin quelque chose
d venir mais physiquement à proprement
parler non pour moi sophie c'est une
jouissance surtout cérébrale mais c'est
vrai que le corps participe aussi qu
elle vous arrive-t-il d'avoir des
orgasmes en conversation cérébraux oui
physiquement
plus qu'à la conversation qui vous a
plus troublé le plus touché est le plus
touché même plus touchés c'était un
homme qui m'appelait alors qu'ils
m'aiment bien expliqué ce qu'il
attendait de moi et qui m'a appelé d'un
hôpital d'un hôpital où sa femme ne
pouvait enfanter et donc il m'appelait
pour jouir pour donner son sperme et
pour qu'il soit
greffé dans le ventre de sa femme je
crois donc ce qu'il attendait de moi en
fait c'était pas une femme très très
érotique vente 1 mais c'était plutôt
tout ce que donne la femme au niveau de
la tendresse dirait confort et de l'ag
sens c'est pour faire du billet prouve
est enfin
battre et r oui et il m'a rappelé je
débutais rappeler - bon parce que c'est
un enfin je vais te fais quelque chose
c'est comme cali mais pourquoi
et puis on va dans une team a rappelé
tous étaient très très bien passé vous
pouvez y ait un bébé qui dit quand ça
oui
c'est presque demain
je m'approche des toiles à tous et
que j'aimais bien quand je suis athée je
n'y vois que
tu seras le bitume sur la tête et
poussant le pied en fin de match estelle
à bien connaître les hommes est-ce que
vous parvenez encore à leur faire
confiance dans votre vie privée
mais j'ai essayé mais je crois qu'à
partir de là certains moments bout
comment cette caserne tu vas j'avais
vous a dit non
plus quel est votre expérience
professionnelle avant de faire ce métier
en espagne un professionnel je fais je
le fais un peu de tout c'est pour ça
j'arrive bien à capter gens par exemple
quel type de métier mais un peu de tout
je vais travailler dans le ménage est
fait pas mal de choses quoi les contacts
avec les gens est ce que vous aimez ce
nouveau métier
ça me fait rire quoi je veux dire je me
sens bien y'a pas de problème se dire ce
qui vous fait le plus rire ouais et puis
que bon ben je suis tranquille quoi je
ne suis pas là entre histoire
complètement n'a de nom tout se passe
bien le métier le plus difficile plus
dure que vous ayez fait
c'est un combat de catch féminin la
crème chantilly mais encore c'est à dire
comment ça se passe mais c'est à dire
qu'on a plein de crème chantilly au bout
d'un moment ils choisissent des clans
d'allassac et asperges de chantilly et
tu nages complètement pour te battre
avec ta fille tu la trappe et hugues
liste pas tellement me veut dire bon
c'est dans les boîtes de nuit les gens
quand ils te regarder sans trop quoi est
ce que ça vaut le contact avec les gens
c'est ça surtout vous aimez le public
ouais beaucoup
trop des fois il n'avait pas l'air du
repas l'air amer en tout cas mais non
pourquoi justement il faut faut pas
avoir l'air dur j'ai l'air que j'ai quoi
je suis natural c'est tout vous avez
déjà vendu votre corps bande annonce je
vais en parler ça moi je le donne ça se
vend pas une chose comme ça
que les cdd aux thèses qui font le
mélange air va savoir et vendre son
corps non je crois franchement c'est
trop m'en serais pas là autant aller
directement là-bas et puis gagner plus
joues et tu venir librement
[Musique]
au
début on en prend très jeune donc j'en
avais marre de travailler j'ai rencontré
quelqu'un et puis
vous avez envie d'un enfant très tôt
pour quelles raisons
manque d'accès
soit nom et votre enfant pièce qui
s'occupe de lui passer une bonne nuit se
nourrie logée chez moi tranquille
aussi je m'occupe à quelques 6 bon je
travaille six heures par jour et j'ai ma
vie privée je veux dire ça ne prend pas
totalement quand même faut pas le cacher
y'a pas beaucoup d'hommes chez vous au
fond par le petit garçon bah je préfère
pas parce que on sait pas ce qu'ils ont
dans la tête racontez nous un peu de
votre enfance et d'une enfance facile
d'abattre est très facile c'est à dire
mais j'y suis allé dans un institut qui
s'appelle l'orphelinat et puis j'y suis
resté jusqu'à l'âge de 15 ans la haine
s'est pas sentie voix qui vous est
coutumier dans
mais moi c'est un truc un sentiment qui
met et coutumes et c'est fort j'ai envie
de me battre pour arriver à faire
quelque chose c'est tout
racontez moi
j'ai été voir le l'adjoint au maire et
je vais menacé que si jamais me donnait
pas un appartement je faisais un malheur
dans son bureau c'est à dire
bah là j'ai sorti les crocs les gros
moyens j'ai sorti un couteau et je me
suis dit s'il ne trouve pas
d'appartement je me tue dans son bureau
et il aura un enfant élevé tout alors
même si vous croyez tout chantage ça
marche et tout c'est pas comme ça vous
aurez l'appartement alors il paraît j'ai
regardé tous tellement dur mentale et
des convaincants la ceni au pape une
semaine après sa maman chevaux dont vous
seriez vraiment tuer
j'en avais marre je me serais pas de
fait mais je préfère voir une cicatrice
comme ça qu'elles séparent ils monfils
en avoir une plus grande parce que si
j'avais pas cet appartement l'on puisse
honorer celle d'un côté et moi l'autre
rien
[Musique]